murderer Orrin Hatch recently attended a
book party for his memoir square peg
confessions of a citizen senator it was
hosted earlier this month by the
Washington law firm of Baker & Hostetler
it's half an hour
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we met years ago
you were there
[Music]
[Music]
oh that's right I'm sorry just talk Jim
Martin that's what I've never seen one
like that that's the Senate staffer pens
uh they're good they're great
[Laughter]
thanks so much well I'm proud of you
doing that job
well you're kind of be that's all I can
say we're grateful to have you here it's
I think your joy there's a lot of fun
one shoe right well a lot of good stuff
in there too very much talk a little bit
about mr. vice versa the other day and
we love it here that's gonna play
together
that's good run you got the gala up
tomorrow that's going to be a tough but
it's going to be only after a really bad
I'm gonna come over and wouldn't you
just a little bit and say hello like an
Alexa game just make it up to me
sure yeah and I'm gonna be mine more a
lot of other people but this is all I
had time
[Music]
you've got a long line of people out
there
it's nice of you to come it really is my
plate I'm so proud of you you're doing a
great job and frankly I thought I said
on network TV I thought the brief in the
in the Michigan case was a stroke of
genius I really did and you know you
know what I'm talking about there hang
in there too
yeah
and it took a talk about it right here
I'm doing my best
Betty says I'm too slow proud to have
you here
let me introduce we're proud of you
proud of which of their who said make it
out to that gym sir okay
by commissioner
[Music]
[Music]
every tobacco farmers during part of the
retreat but otherwise I'll be there
good luck
parcel is 8% your grandmother's
come on sweet they're good between us
good between Elena me
money lane good in there
áthe RI ma
Mord reading in there so nice to come
myself I know how much I appreciated by
adverbs that I would always do this
there are supporting me very strongly
there but you hang in there
okay my mate Katherine Harris is the
secretary of state down there this is
above and beyond you know governor lame
you know governor Gilmore who said make
an end to them good congratulations on
your boy it turned out all right
who do I make it out to Jim this is so
nice of you to come fire to do something
like this but I don't have the time oh
yeah I think you'll like it let me know
what you think what you it's a lot of
humor but a lot of very serious things
in here as well so I think you'll enjoy
oh here we go okay thank you
yeah you know hoping a good job job and
because I do think you'd be hard
wait wait just a second hey uncle Ted
what are you doing here I got it you
can't do one for Lily it's Li ly okay
and the other one is for Katherine
what does it say I by proxy judge
Stevens I think we can get up through
tell me a - that's forecast me it's a
couple of bucks another class of
taxpayer dollars on that cheap you're
gonna watch for Utah
so is aka th our YMCA that's what I
thought CA th er any
you know what they say thanks for coming
that's so nice of you
let's get a picture
maybe here more popular my district
tonight that's gonna make it out to Tom
yes sir
[Music]
thank you well you're great glad to have
you with us kid thanks again
[Music]
thanks to make us we're gonna miss you
there but you're gonna do kind of a help
in any way I can because you've been a
great one
you're the bear the legislation itself
is so nice and now wait confessions yeah
a senior citizen is a senator other
other than others and Oren's wonderful
wife Elaine Lauren hatch has no greater
friend fan admirer and advocate
then Betty Murphy now Betty's practice
law with us for twenty two years since
she stepped down as chair of the NLRB
funded as she was an NLRB chair under
President Ford and Carter we do not call
her madam chairman we don't dare call
her square peg we just call her our
partner and what you actually call her
what the Washington Post once called her
a consummate labor lawyer I give you
Betty Murphy I'm not sure how to
interpret that sound but I am absolutely
delighted Orin is still in there doing
if someone should tell him that he
doesn't have to side at the moment but
he's still signing books it really is so
wonderful to have friends who write
books I mean many of you here have
written books and I buy my friends books
I buy the books and I read the books and
I buy books for my friends
give him his presence and I have read
Orrin Hatch's book and I don't sell
something I haven't read the book book
is really a very interesting book it is
one that shows a boy and a man of modest
circumstances who when he got married
you probably all know this lived in a
converted chicken coop with his wife and
children and then became a u.s. senator
the chairman of the Senate Labor
Committee and now chairman of the
Judiciary Committee but one commercial
ad tonight
one ad now that he's chairman more
partners
that's good son all right now that
you're chairman of the Judiciary
Committee again I hope you're going to
get some of these judges through so well
it's really a great honor to be here
because of an orange
it gives me great pleasure to have you
here tonight and before there's a
surprise for you this coming up you have
to duck when it comes but there's a
surprise and when it does you'll see
what it is but before then would you
like to give your greetings to bigger
and Hostetler's guests this is really
impressive to me after associated with
that rowdy bunch up there in Capitol
Hill to be among all your decent
honorable people I have to say that Ted
Stevens came tonight the chairman of the
Appropriations Committee and I signed
two books for him and he said this is
gonna cost me at least 100 million
dollars and I told him a lot more than
that but let me just say that I hope you
enjoyed this but I am so honored to have
all of you here it's just unbelievable I
mean I know that when Betty does
something in her law firm bill and all
the others when they do things that's
really done right
and I even I'm shocked at this and I
know that you all were ordered to be
here so you but yeah I have been known
to March the Betty speed whenever she
tells me to but let me put that up there
okay but I'm very grateful to you Betty
I'm grateful to all of you this means a
lot to me because you know I think
you're gonna find square peg to be an
interesting rate even if I say so myself
there's a lot of humor in there a lot of
self-deprecation I really let it all
hang out I don't know if I ever get
reelected after this part but most
people have ratted of have really
enjoyed it and they most all of them
have told me that they've learned a lot
from it but there are a lot of humorous
things in there I'll never forget when
bono I first met Bono Bobby Shriver Ted
Kennedy's nephew the eunice Kennedy
Shriver her son who lives in Hollywood
and loves it out there he brings Bono in
to see me the great rock star and I met
him and I was really impressed
I thought he one of the most horrible
looking shoes I've ever seen a month but
he's a terrific human being and you know
here's the family worth hundreds of
millions of dollars in the entertainment
world who who takes time out of his very
busy schedule could sit back on his
laurels and enjoy his money but he takes
time to get to put a real effort in to
try and help first with sub-saharan
African debt relief and then then the
problems of AIDS in many respects the
race in the president has has put so
many billions of dollars into into AIDS
in the next couple of years is because
of work done by by many people Ted
Stevens is one of them but Bono is one
of them the three-eighths bills were at
Kennedy Kennedy hatch bills and I talked
about that friendship relationship that
I have with Ted in this book as you know
I came here to fight him and we do fight
about 96% of the time but but when we
get together everybody else tends to get
out of the way because they figure if
hatch and Kennedy can get together
anybody can but bono came to me and and
we first help them with sub-saharan
African debt relief and and did some
very good things there and he deserves a
lot of credit for it and then we worked
on AIDS and finally the third time he
came he said hey senator he said I'd
like to hear your music and I said well
gee and that's music - - so I played
them two or three songs he said senator
he said that's a beautiful he said that
the brothers are never going to sing it
and I said well well why not and they
said because of who you are you know
conservative Republican Mormon I mean
get my goodness wouldn't three strikes
against you right there according to
some people and and I said well what do
I do about that he said well you've got
to change your name and I said well what
should I change my name to it he gets
looks really content it looks up at the
cilia finally says I've got it he said
Johnnie trapdoor so have you seen any
music by Johnny trapdoor you'll know
exactly who the writer in fact I got a
call shortly after that from from Ronnie
Dunn of Brooks & Dunn the great country
team and Ronnie Dunn said hey seminary
said I want to write some music with you
I said well that'd be great and he said
but you got to use your stage name and
your sobriquet and I said well what do
you mean he said
Johnny trapdoor so when you say a song
that Brooks and I are saying written by
Johnny trapdoor you know exactly who it
is but there's a lot of humorous stuff
in here one of the and there's a lot of
very serious stuff for instance I wrote
a chapter on embryonic stem-cell
research
it's a very difficult issue and they're
wonderful and wonderfully sincere people
on both sides of that issue but it's
very difficult to understand and it took
me well well past a year of really
intensive study meeting with the top
ethicists the top scientists Nobel
laureates religious leaders and a lot of
Prayer it was very difficult getting to
the point where I thought I knew I'd
have to make a decision but it was an
easy decision in the end because I
believe that the mosan pro-life position
is to help the living as well and
frankly wherever I go I have pro-life
people coming up to me and saying you
know you're right on that now there are
others who do very sincerely feel that
I'm wrong but I have to do what I
believe is right and that's why I guess
they call me a square peg now me it was
the it was the publisher has suggested
that for two reasons I suppose one is
they consider it it's a fairly liberal
group of people in this publishing house
called basic books and one reason is I
think they really think and I am a
square
they know I'm a squirrel and the second
is they know that I don't feel it fit in
any particular holes and it's because I
try to do what is right regardless of
politics this book kind of brings that
out it starts off with labor law reform
and one of the one of the great stories
was when I came on the Judiciary
Committee and I won't keep any longer
I'll just tell this one story when I
came on the Judiciary Committee yes Jim
Eastland a hard-nosed old curmudgeon
from Mississippi was chairman of the
committee and you know he started
drinking at 9:00 a.m. in the morning and
if you didn't drink with him you were in
trouble well he knew I was a Mormon and
didn't drink so he offered it to me but
I refused and for some reason he took a
liking to me so one night we were on the
floor late at night it was 8 o'clock
everybody was tired most people were
irritated we hadn't need eaten and he
came up to me on the floor and he never
called me Senator ORN he always just
barked out hatch so so he can let me
said hatch I said yes sir as any dutiful
freshman senator would and he said how
am I going to dinner with me and I said
ok so we went downstairs the Senate
dining room to dinner and we were
sitting there for 20 minutes and he
didn't say a word to me he kept eating
his soup and looking me and finally
after about 20 minutes he looks up at me
and he said hatch I said yes sir he said
do you think we can save this country
bushy-tailed freshman senator and I
looked him right in the eyes and I said
yes sir we can whereupon he looked me
right back in the eyes and he said
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
that was my introduction to the
Judiciary Committee and it's got
downhill from there there's all of you
know tomorrow we will begin the debate
on Miguel Estrada and it's gonna be a
tough debate I don't think anybody's
laid a hand on the gale and he's one of
the truly great success stories of
America but we'll have to see what
happens on the floor there's been some
indication that the Democrats might
filibuster the first Hispanic in the
history of this country to be nominated
to the Circuit Court of Appeals for the
District of Columbia admittedly the
Circuit Court of Appeals for the
District of Columbia is one of the
greatest and most powerful courts in the
land second only to the Supreme Court
and in some ways even more powerful
because they hear thousands of cases the
Supreme Court and every year that effect
almost everybody in America and in many
cases everybody in America
migaila will make a great addition there
if we can get them get them on the court
and I believe we will before it's over I
think cooler heads will prevail as we've
had to have them prevail on our side
during the Clinton years and hopefully
Miguel will take his place as one of the
great judges in this country but these
are the type of things that I deal with
on a daily basis are not easy they're
very very difficult and you get some
insights through a reading square ping
publisher asked me to write another book
about my hardscrabble existence and I
started to I wrote that one two
Christmases ago and ahead it took a week
and just wrote it now a hundred ninety
single-spaced typewritten pages into the
next one I'm not sure anybody I want to
read it but it's been a wonderful
experience for me because when I got to
my to ten years of age in my life uh
yeah that was when my brother died in
the Second World War he was on the plus
state oil raid over the Benevento
Austrian and Romanian oil fields and he
was knows gonna be 24 liberated and they
had been shut down before and got back
through enemy lines with the help of the
Judas love iane partisans or underground
partisans or underground and this time
he didn't make it back he was listed as
missing in action and and then a short
number of years later they they found
what were his remains and we went
through it again but I have all the
letters that he wrote to my mother and I
started through those I had kind of just
never really read them and I'll tell you
it was the most thrilling thing that
I've been through in a long time he was
18 and 19 and 20
he couldn't spell he was a high school
graduate couldn't spell he didn't know
grammar hardly at all and ran paragraphs
together but his spirit comes through
those letters in such a dramatic
wonderful way that I yeah it just made
my whole life I won't tell anymore
because there I wanna bore you to death
but but it's fun for me to write and it
is true that I did try to write in
various forms and and in particular I
hope you like this book I am so grateful
that all of you are here tonight it is
such a wonderful thing to me and tell
you my wife Elaine's standing right over
here who's my wife now 46 years and
[Applause]
you'll find from the book that she put
up with an awful lot during all that
time but we we have six children and 20
grandchildren the 21st is on its way
that's all I know about that's on its
way but but this book tells a little bit
about some of these things that we've
been doing over these last 27 years I
want to pay respect to my fellow members
of Congress who are here tonight it's so
nice of all of you to come it's meant so
much to me and and I just want you all
to know that I love you and appreciate
you it's a wonderful thing to be in the
United States Senate I can't always say
that with a straight face but I but I
really mean it and there are many many
wonderful stories and I hope that square
peg will give you some insights that you
would not otherwise have
thanks so much it's great to be here
[Applause]
just one second here okay I was gonna go
in and sign some more he's gonna sign
some more books but we've got one got a
little surprise it is a wonderful thing
in senator hatch says to be a United
States Senator it's even better to be
the best author among those the United
States senators and for that we have a
small celebration of that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so nice you to take time in out busy our
- thanks
so to make it a deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Utah senator Orrin Hatch is serving his
fifth term in the US Senate his memoir
square peg confessions of a citizen
senator is published by basic books
online at basic books calm what is the
back